ANNIE MA-WEAVER:
Hello, everyone.
I'm Annie Ma-Weaver, a partner
manager with Google Cloud.
SHAN KULANDAIVEL: And I'm Shan
Kulandaivel, a product manager
with Google Cloud,
coming to you live
from our homes and basement.
And thanks for taking
the time to join us today
for this special event.
ANNIE MA-WEAVER:
We've got content
organized in three sections.
One, why Google Cloud for High
Performance Computing or HPC?
Two, some of our product
capabilities that support HPC.
And three, highlighting
some of our awesome partners
that work with us to make
our customers successful.
If there's one thing that we
want you to walk away with,
it's a Google Cloud
democratizes HPC.
And we want to enable
HPC the Google way,
through our partnerships
and product portfolio.
Let's start with HPC
for Google Cloud.
We want to share some real world
examples of HPC in action--
and how GCP is contributing.
One of the topics that is top
of mind for us, and for many
of us, is COVID-19 and
the scientific research
being performed to
develop diagnostic tools
and a possible vaccine.
A number of different
scientific efforts are underway.
There are teams working
on discovering new drugs
for treating COVID-19 patients.
Others are focused on genomics,
developing better techniques
through genetic screening.
There are teams that are running
molecular simulations to better
understand how the virus impacts
human cells and the effects
various treatments can have.
All of these problems
are HPC problems,
where you have to perform
large numbers of computations.
And in some, there is also a
large amount of data involved,
making HPC even more critical
for completing these workloads
in a timely manner.
Google has joined hands
with industry partners
to create the COVID-19
HPC consortium.
This consortium has gathered
now more than 60 projects,
with hundreds of petaflops,
millions of CPU cores,
and tens of thousands of GPUs
dedicated to COVID-19 research.
In some sense, applying HPC
to such research problems
is not new.
However, what is
new is that this
is an unprecedented
situation, one
that requires rapid response
and unfettered collaboration
across research groups, drawn
from academia and industry.
Depending on the scenarios,
researchers need access
to new technologies--
in some cases, accelerators
like GPUs and TPUs--
so that they can run their
simulations and machine
learning models faster.
In other cases, they need
access to new software.
Last but not least, given the
experimentation driven nature
of the research, users need
on-demand access to resources,
since they don't
know which project
is going to lead to success.
And they need the ability
to adeptly allocate
resources as needed.
How do you overcome
these challenges?
We believe cloud
computing in general,
and Google Cloud, specifically,
has solutions and tools
to address them.
Google Cloud is
playing a small part,
and I want to emphasize that
Google Cloud's contribution
pales in comparison
to the efforts
that researchers and other
individuals are putting in.
Nonetheless, Google Cloud
is helping where we can.
Let me tell you more about
a specific COVID-19 project,
where we're playing a part.
One team at Harvard
Medical School
is screening ultra-large
libraries of chemical compounds
to accelerate the drug
discovery process.
Using a grant of
Google Research credits
for the first protein
target of interest,
the team at Harvard built on
the scalable processing of GCP
and Slurm, a scheduler that
Google Cloud supports, to run
80,000 cores at the same time--
and to analyze more than one
billion compounds in five days.
Using GCP and Google credits
to scale up its computations,
the team is able to conduct
ultra-large virtual screenings
much faster than ever before.
As of May 2020, the team
has targeted 16 proteins
with 40 target sites and run
35 billion docking instances,
using 750 million CPU hours.
Next, my teammate
Shan will share
how Google Cloud helps
other organizations facing
similar HPC challenges.
SHAN KULANDAIVEL:
You may be wondering
how relevant these
challenges that Annie talked
about in the context
of COVID research
are relevant to you, your
user, and organizations.
Now, whether you're
a large organization
with a significant HPC budget,
or a smaller startup that
is just starting
up, there are always
projects where
you and your users
need to collaborate better.
There are going
to be cases where
you want to experiment
with new technologies,
so that you can bring new
products to market much,
much faster.
And lastly, you always want
to have the flexibility
and ability to respond faster
to changing business needs--
and do not want
to be constrained
by typical procurement cycles.
In short, you want to be agile.
What I see, working with
many, many customers,
is that many of these challenges
are even more pronounced
for customers from commercial
and industrial backgrounds,
more so than research
institutions.
That is primarily because the
need for security controls
is higher, and typical
procurement policies are not
designed with agility in mind.
Just as Google Cloud is able
to address these challenges
for COVID researchers, it can
help customers in mainstream
industries as well.
Let's look at some specifics.
One of the biggest
challenges customers face
is the [INAUDIBLE]
of the infrastructure
that you deploy on premises.
The chart on this slide
is an illustration
of the business impact of
having a fixed infrastructure.
When you have infrastructure
with fixed capacity,
that are going to be times
when the infrastructure is
underutilized.
And more importantly,
there are going
to be times when the
infrastructure is
oversubscribed, which
means some of your users
are going to face extended wait
times, which translates either
into delayed products
or the inability
to respond quickly
to new market needs.
This is all in addition
to the challenge of having
an infrastructure that
can quickly go out of date
and not meet the
needs of your users.
We talked about how
HPC infrastructure
is deployed on premises
and some of the challenges.
With Google Cloud,
you can address
all of those challenges.
First and foremost, you have
access to elastic compute
and storage, which means you get
to provision the resources that
are the right size
for your application,
nothing more and nothing less.
Second, you also get
access to new technologies,
be it new software technologies
or new hardware platforms.
A group in your
organization may want
to deploy GPUs for a new
algorithm or a new application
that they are developing.
And with Cloud, you are able to
do that in an on-demand manner,
where as in on-premises, you
have to wait multiple weeks
or multiple months
to deploy GPUs--
and then figure out
who is going to go
manage that infrastructure.
Lastly, Google Cloud
also makes data
sharing with internal and
external collaborators
easy and secure.
By having all of
your data centrally
collected and curated, you
can effectively and securely
share it with users that
need to have access to it.
But also you retain control.
You are able to be
deprovision access when
a user or a group of users don't
need access to data any more,
or you can very quickly
provision access
when new users join
your organization.
A number of customers
today use Google Cloud
for those very same reasons.
Customers across industries,
ranging from life sciences
to financial services to chip
design to weather modeling,
all use Google Cloud today.
That is in addition to a
number of research institutions
that use Google Cloud today and
get the benefits of a globally
available, secure, scalable,
and on-demand infrastructure.
You can find details about
these and other customers
at cloud.google.com/customers.
With that, let me pivot
and talk a little bit
about some of the
products and services that
are available to
customers on our platform.
The most critical aspect
for HPC applications
is having a highly reliable
and scalable infrastructure
that is delivered as
an on-demand service.
To that end, Google
Cloud's infrastructure
as a service product,
spanned the breadth and depth
of what users need.
Compute Engine, which
is the virtual machines
product in Google Cloud,
provides flexible size
virtual machines that start up
in seconds while also allowing
for custom configuration
of processor, memory,
and persistent
storage to best suit
the needs of your applications.
Compute Engine VMs also
support Linux and Windows
operating systems,
thereby allowing
you to move applications that
need both Linux and Windows
operating systems
to Google Cloud.
You have the flexibility to
choose between Intel, and AMD
processors.
You also get a
choice of processors
that are optimized
for high clock
speed and vertically
scaling applications,
versus those that are optimized
for scale out applications.
There are a number of
sessions in the Compute--
[AUDIO OUT] the details of the
Compute Engine virtual machines
product, I highly recommend
watching some of those.
Engine is backed by Google
Cloud's high performance
software defined network.
The computer
networking [AUDIO OUT]
VMs between themselves, as well
as [AUDIO OUT] and the internet
with high throughput,
low latency networking.
Similarly, Google Cloud offers
an array of storage products,
ranging from object storage
to file based storage.
We'll cover some of the
details of the storage
and networking products
in the subsequent slides.
This one specific
virtual machine type
that I want to highlight--
a new product that we launched
last year, C2 [INAUDIBLE]
for Compute Optimized
Virtual Machines
is a new VM type that is
optimized for HPC applications.
It provides 3.8 gigahertz
of sustained clock speed.
It provides full transparency
into the underlying server
architecture, thereby enabling
advance performance tuning.
It also supports up to
three terabytes of local SSD
for high speed ephemeral
storage and provides
32 Gbps of network throughput.
C2 VMs also include a
number of software features
that HPC applications
can take advantage of.
For example, it supports
new mobile applications,
which enables applications
to further improve
their performance by
reducing memory access times.
In order to better
support HPC workloads,
we also launched a capability
that gives customers
control over the
physical placement
of their virtual machines.
When it comes to inter-node
latency in a HPC cluster,
[INAUDIBLE] come into play.
The further apart your
nodes are, the more time
it is going to take
for packets to be
exchanged between the
nodes in your cluster.
There are algorithms,
often referred to as IT
couple algorithms, that are
very sensitive to this latency.
As a result, we now
give you the ability
to set a policy that
insulates our placement
algorithms to place the virtual
machines as close as possible.
And in most cases,
that is going to be
within the same physical
data center rack,
so that you get the lowest
possible latency possible.
One of the reasons customers
want to move to cloud
is so that they can
optimize their spend
and get the most value
for their cloud spend.
There are quite a few mechanisms
available in Google Cloud that
allows you to optimize
your TCO, but I
want to highlight a couple
that really speak to the way
that Google Cloud in general has
been architected and engineered
from ground up to give
you the flexibility.
The first, our custom
machine types--
the ability to create
virtual machines
with the amount of CPU
and memory that you need.
While you may be familiar with
predefined virtual machines
that you may have used
in a different cloud
environment, which by the way,
is optimized for provider's
efficiency rather than
customers' TCO, in Google
Cloud by adjusting
a slider, you can
choose the amount of CPU
and memory that you need.
And Google Cloud is the only
place where that is possible.
Next, Google Cloud has a feature
called Sustained Use Discounts
that automatically gives
you bigger discounts
the more you use your
virtual machines.
There is no custom policy that
you need to set as a user.
There is no subscription.
There is no special flag
that you need to activate.
Just use your virtual machines,
and the more you use it,
you get a bigger discount.
These two capabilities
are in addition
to some of the
other capabilities
that you see
elsewhere, as well--
Committed Use Discounts, which
gives you a bigger discount
if you commit for a
longer duration of time,
Preemptible VMs, which
gives you up to 80%
of discount, which is
great for workloads
that can tolerate failures.
CPUs are great for a
broad set of workloads.
That's why we all use CPUs.
However, there are
algorithms that
benefit from the massive
amount of parallelism
that accelerators,
such as GPUs, offer.
On Google Cloud, in addition
to offering AMD and Intel CPUs,
we provide in in-media GPUs
that Annie will talk about
in a little bit--
and the custom design and
built ASA for machine learning,
called TPUs.
On the one hand, GPUs enable
graphics visualization
and can also be used as general
purpose computation units
for speeding up your
algorithms, including
machine learning algorithms.
On the other hand, DPUs, short
for Denser Processing Units,
are specifically
designed for machine
learning use cases
in mind by Google--
and help accelerate the time
to solution for AI and machine
learning applications.
Storage services are a critical
part of cloud infrastructure
and play a very important
role for HPC applications.
Google Cloud provides a
breadth of storage options,
some offered from Google and
some offered from our partners,
such as DDN and Netapp,
and customers can apply
their [INAUDIBLE] [AUDIO OUT]
to their HPC apps.
They can deploy a scale
out Filestore or using
Cloud Filestore.
If they need a parsecs
compliant powerful system,
they can deploy Lustre file
system that is provided by DDN
and is available
in our marketplace.
Cloud Storage
volumes from Netapp
are [AUDIO OUT] cloud
network attached storage.
Now in all of these
cases, customers
can use Google Cloud Storage
for cost efficient cold storage
of data, irrespective of
what storage system is
in use in their HPC cluster.
Finally, they can also use
Data Transfer tools that are
provided by Google to move
data from their on-premises
environment into
Google Cloud Storage--
and then use that
as a staging ground
to hydrate their HPC clusters.
No infrastructure
can be HPC ready
without strong
networking capabilities,
particularly for tightly
coupled applications.
As I said earlier, the fully
software defined network
that Google Cloud operates
provides all the policy
driven controls that you would
expect from a modern SDN--
but at the same time
provides raw performance
that you need for your
network performance
sensitive applications.
Google Cloud currently
supports up to 32 Gbps on VMs
and up to 100 Gbps of
throughput for GPUs.
The software defined
network gives customers
control of networking policies,
such as firewall controls,
a global VPC, and
an architecture
for multi-region applications.
You can now run MPI
applications in Google Cloud.
We support both open MPI
and Intel MPI applications.
And in fact, we just
recently published a set
of optimization
scripts and a guide
for tuning your application
on Google Cloud.
You can find those tools in
Google Cloud's GitHub project.
With that, I want to
be mindful of the time
and hand it back over to Annie
for her to talk about Google
Cloud's partners and how
they help you be successful
in our platform.
ANNIE MA-WEAVER:
Thanks, Shan, for
that helpful and
comprehensive discussion
of how GCP enables HPC
through our products.
Next, let's talk about how
our partnerships enable HPC
workloads.
A typical HPC workload
has a few key components.
Some of these are
necessarily and best
served by a cloud service
provider like Google Cloud,
such as pricing
models, accelerators,
and the fundamentals-- compute,
storage, networking, et cetera.
Other layers of the stack
are often domain specific.
Examples include applications,
tools, libraries,
and management platforms.
It is not possible
for Google alone
to tackle the wide array of
offerings and requirements
that exist at these levels.
We are able to provide complete
end to end solutions for HPC
thanks to our partners.
Our partners, some
of which I will
cover in greater detail
in the following slides,
complement and complete
our native stack.
With their know
how and technology,
we are able to deliver
end-to-end solutions
to enable our customers
to quickly and easily run
HPC workloads on GCP.
The first partner
I'd like to highlight
is SchedMD, which has built
the market-leading open source
scheduler, Slurm.
Google Cloud teamed
up with SchedMD
to release a set of
tools that make it easier
to launch the Slurm workload
manager on Compute Engine--
and to expand your existing
cluster dynamically,
when you need extra resources.
This integration was
built by the experts
at SchedMD, in accordance
with Slurm best practices.
Google Cloud is the only public
cloud provider through which
SchedMD has built these
optimized Slurm scripts,
thanks to our partnership.
For those interested in
trying out the scripts today,
please scan the QR
code on the slide
to be redirected to a code
lab that will teach you how
to run a Slurm cluster on GCP.
In March of this year, SchedMD
released version 3 of the Slurm
on GCP scripts, which are
available on its GitHub page.
Please visit the codelab,
SchedMD's GitHub,
and reach out to your
Cloud account team
to learn more
about Slurm on GCP.
The next partner I'd like
to highlight is NVIDIA.
We are proud to offer five GPU
families on GCP, with a new GPU
family, the A100s, coming soon.
On Google Cloud
Marketplace, we have
50 plus NVIDIA
Google Cloud, or NGC,
containers available--
and 600 plus GPU
accelerated HPC applications.
Also for HPC,
NVIDIA has recently
released an SDK that supports
GPU accelerated HPC modeling
and simulation applications.
You can learn more about
our partnership with NVIDIA,
including how we're enabling
industry specific use cases,
at thepoweroftwo.solutions.
Last but not least, you can find
sessions presented by Googlers
at GTC 2020 at the
short link on the slide.
We set up our GPUs
in pass through mode,
so you can experience
bare metal performance.
And with the
flexibility of cloud,
you can attach up to eight
GPUs to your instance and mix
and match different Google
Cloud resources to build
your tailored infrastructure.
And of course, our
typical features apply.
You can preempt a GPU and take
advantage of per second billing
and sustained use discounts.
Google Cloud offers a
range of in NVIDIA GPUs,
whether you need cost effective
inference or scale up or scale
out training.
As I mentioned earlier,
we have a suite
of five GPUs available today.
K80 started machine learning
training workloads years ago.
P100, B100 are top of the line
GPU is for high end training.
P4 and T4 are great
for inference.
Did you know that we were
the first hyperscale cloud
to launch with these GPUs?
We are also the only
public cloud that
has T4 GPUs available globally.
We're also excited to
announce forthcoming support
for the new NVIDIA end peer
architecture and the NVIDIA
A100 tensor core GPU.
Next, I want to tell
you about Rescale.
Rescale offers an industry
leading HPC management platform
that runs on public
cloud infrastructure,
solving the common challenges
of implementing and managing
cloud and on-premise HPC
infrastructure resources
in enterprise environments.
At the end of last year,
Rescale completed an integration
of its platform
with Google Cloud,
and we launched
a joint offering.
Key segments that we are
targeting with Rescale
include electronic design
automation, manufacturing,
and health care
and life sciences.
You can learn more
about Rescale and GCP
at the link on the slide.
Rescale offers a
single portal that
can manage all of your HPC
the applications and data.
The portal runs on top of
Google Cloud infrastructure,
allowing you to quickly
ramp up your consumption.
Rescale's portfolio features 400
plus leading HPC applications
and provides extensive
coverage of critical workloads
for aerospace, automotive,
industrial manufacturing,
semiconductor, and
energy sectors.
Customers can take advantage
of Rescale's focused solution
for HPC, combined with the
customizable, practically
limitless infrastructure
of Google Cloud.
Rescale has years of experience
partnering with software
and hardware providers to pursue
HPC workloads and enterprise
accounts with its
direct sales force.
It also has a team of HPC
hardware and software experts
ready to assist you in
accelerating migration
of your workflows to the cloud.
Again, you can learn more
about Rescale on GCP today
at Rescale.com/GCP.
Last but not least,
I'd like to highlight
one of our storage partners that
focuses on HPC workloads, DDN.
DDN has an offering available
on our Google Cloud Marketplace
called EXAScaler Cloud.
EXAScaler Cloud is a
scalable parallel file
system, purpose
built for AI, HPC,
and other big data workloads.
Ideally suited for dynamic
pay as you go applications,
from rapid simulation
and prototyping
to cloud bursting
peak HPC workloads,
EXAScaler Cloud helps maximize
storage performance and cost
effectiveness with GCP.
The marketplace offering also
features 24 by 7 support.
To learn more, you can visit
our marketplace today or contact
cloud@ddn.com.
As I shared at the
top of the session,
if there's one thing we want you
to walk away with, it's this.
Google Cloud
democratizes HPC, and we
want to enable HPC
the Google way,
through our partnerships
and product portfolio.
If you'd like to learn
more about our HPC products
and partnerships, here
are recommendations
for related sessions to help
augment your understanding.
Thank you for your
time and attention.
We really appreciate it.